we are in the beginning of a mass
extinction
and all you can talk about is the money
and
fairy tales of eternal economic growth
how dare you when greta dunbar drew
national attention for her comments at
the un
in the summer of 2019 some praised her
performance as a stinging rebuke to the
rich and powerful for failing to put the
survival of the planet
above their own needs at just 16 years
old our next guest is already changing
the world pick for the 2019.
she became the biggest voice on the
biggest issue
facing the planet others saw the
exploitation of a young woman with
emotional problems for propagandistic
ends
a mentally ill swedish child who is
being exploited by her parents
and by the international area but
there's no question that dunberg's style
of environmentalism
strident urgent and critical of global
capitalism has gained a strong foothold
in contemporary politics
a 2019 paper from the journal
biosciences cosigned by more than 11 000
scientists
asserted that planet earth's population
must be stabilized
and ideally gradually reduced and some
politicians have questioned the morality
of having children at all
there's scientific consensus that the
lives of children are going to be very
difficult
and it does lead i think young people to
have a legitimate question you know
should
is it okay to still have children
educating everyone
on the need to curb population growth
seems a reasonable campaign to enact
would you be courageous enough to
discuss this issue and make it a key
feature of a plan to address
climate catastrophe well martha the
answer is yes
fears of overpopulation and ecological
disaster are also beginning to manifest
on the far right
mixed in with an anti-immigrant animus
the logic was expressed in its most
dramatic and twisted form in the 2019
manifestos of mass shooters
in both new zealand and texas if we can
get rid of enough people he wrote then
our way of life can become more
sustainable
whether contemporary proponents of these
ideas know it or not they're all
intellectual heirs of the misguided 18th
century thinker
robert thomas malthus who believed that
when human population increased
famine and environmental destruction
would ensue malthus argued that
population would always outstrip food
supply because population would grow at
exponential rates whereas food supply
could only
grow what he called arithmetic rates
reason science correspondent ron bailey
is the author of the 2015 book
end of doom he didn't recognize that in
fact crops
and livestock are also populations that
they can also be exponentially increased
at the same time as a human population
was
and that's exactly what happened
basically the malthusian prescription
turns out to be completely wrong
in the contemporary world malthusianism
was most famously expressed through the
work of ecologist paul ehrlich
especially in his 1968 book the
population bomb
the only hope that there is is that we
will be able at least in the united
states
through the political process to get a
government that's courageous enough to
say look we're overpopulated we have to
have population control and start moving
in that direction
he predicted that through the 1970s and
80s hundreds of millions would starve to
death
he compared humanity to a cancer writing
that we must shift our efforts from
treatment of the symptoms
to the cutting out of the cancer ehrlich
who still holds an endowed professorship
at stanford didn't respond to our
interview request
his proposed solutions included taxing
diapers subsidizing vasectomies and even
spiking food aid and water supplies with
sterilizing drugs
and then holding a lottery for access to
the antidote
similarly ecologist garrett hardin in
1968 compared humanity to overbreeding
cattle
writing that the freedom to breed is
intolerable the only way to make this
system work is
to have the family be willing to give up
one of its former freedoms namely the
freedom to determine how many children
it was going to have
ehrlich would turn out to be as
wrong-headed as malthus over the next
half
century calories available per capita
steadily increased in just about every
region of the world thanks largely to
improved agricultural techniques and
technology
humans are not only consumers we're also
producers we're able to
create new things to use resources in
better and better ways over time
human creativity can overcome the
problems that malthusians think that
we're going to be suffering
from over consumption we're using fewer
and fewer resources to get more and more
value over time
and yet world hunger is yet to be
eradicated with the un reporting that
about 10
of the global population is
undernourished and perhaps it's true
that past trends don't predict the
future
that's a lot of people how are we going
to feed them all karen pitts who was a
member of the sierra club and ran a
northern california subcommittee on
population growth is concerned that the
world won't be able to accommodate a
population that's expected to peak at 11
billion by 2100
she became interested in the topic after
a trip to china in 1996.
as you flew over the country every space
was taken up by houses and housing they
are
overpopulated whether or not they
produce enough food is a big question
and we really can't take the risk of
being wrong
while it's true that farmers will have
to become 70 more efficient over the
next 30 years to feed the growing
population
the technology already exists to
accomplish that goal
if all farmers were as efficient as u.s
corn growers the world could feed 10
billion people today
on half as much land and as humanity
continues moving into cities
the environment will likely be better
protected bayley points out because this
allows for the restoration of forests
and other ecosystems on the land
migrants leave behind
something like 90 percent of people will
be living in cities by the end of the
century
if that is the case there will be less
than 2 billion people living on the
landscape
which means that there'll be far more
scope for forests to return
for biodiversity to flourish and we'll
be using a lot less resources over that
time
but today's malthusians are most
concerned about the disruptive effects
of
climate change citing global warming
documentarian david attenborough
described humanity
as a plague upon the earth i can't think
of a single problem
that wouldn't be easier to solve if
there were less people
and the biosciences paper signed by
eleven thousand scientists
projects total societal collapse if
population
isn't managed properly we scientists
have a moral obligation
to clearly warn humanity of any
catastrophic threat it is more severe
than anticipated threatening natural
ecosystems and the fate of humanity
there's a catastrophizing
apocalyptic undercurrent ted nordhaus
who is a founder of the breakthrough
institute which advocates technological
solutions to environmental problems
believes the environmental movement has
long been hindered by its anti-growth
paradigm
conventional environmental ideology
posits human development and
environmental
protection oppositionally and i have
exactly the opposite view
nordhouse says that the most effective
way to deal with climate change is by
promoting policies that accelerate
economic growth
if you're really serious about
accelerating the decline of fertility
rates
and the peak and stabilization of global
population
you need to accelerate economic
development for
certainly probably three or four billion
people
over the next three or four decades most
of today's environmentalists don't
openly advocate for the draconian
population control measures
pushed by ehrlich and other malthusians
in the 1970s
karen pitts says she just wants more sex
education and greater access to birth
control in the developing world pointing
to a project she participated in with
tanzania's local population
i have introduced contraception we put
tablets over there that they could use
plus being able to administer family
planning and the contraception rate
went from about 25
to over 54 surprisingly easy those women
wanted
family planning funding greater access
to birth control and education for women
in developing countries was also a
recommendation of the biosciences paper
and it's a policy agenda of the un
and leading ngos like the bill and
melinda gates foundation
nordhaus says such measures can help
with the margins but ultimately miss the
big picture which is that as wealth
increases
fertility rates naturally fall as
families invest more resources
in fewer children the real drivers of
long-term
fertility decline and population
stabilization around the world are just
kind of garden variety economic
development which a lot of the same
people signing those documents are
actually
saying is the problem the biosciences
paper argues that economic growth is
driving over consumption of resources
and says our goals need to shift from
gdp growth and the pursuit of affluence
towards sustaining ecosystems as soon as
we find new ways to do it our
consumption increases
that's the problem pitts is right that
people in wealthier societies tend to
consume resources
and generate greenhouse gases at rates
that are orders of magnitude higher than
those in the third world but nordhaus
points out that when poor societies
become wealthy there are more people
positioned to help
solve environmental problems in the only
way that really works
with new technology environmental
discourse
has been overly focused on consumption
technology
is one of the key things that mediates
the relationship
between affluence and consumption and
impacts
wealthier more developed societies are
both better positioned to adapt
to problems like climate change and
climate impacts a category 5
hurricane creates a lot more devastation
and a lot more loss of life
and human impact in a poorer society
than in a rich society they're also
better positioned to develop and deploy
new technology
most of the success we've had in
deploying
nuclear other clean energy technologies
is actually in context where energy
demand
is growing quickly and so north house
advocates for greater reliance on clean
abundant energy like
nuclear power to fuel advanced economies
towards possibly innovating
even lower impact alternatives but the
third world may still need to rely on
traditional fossil fuels on its path to
prosperity
certainly over the next three or four
decades a lot of development
particularly
in poor countries is still going to be
fossil based but it could be natural gas
and not coal
or in africa for instance just there's
huge
hydro capacity in projections of sort of
where populations are going to stabilize
or
is really when you get down to the
bottom of it is just ultimately a
question of how rapidly
africa develops economically nordhouse
says that climate change will likely
continue to present
challenges for governments individuals
and societies in the coming decades but
that it's better to conceive the problem
not as an asteroid hurtling towards
earth dooming us to extinction
unless we thwart it but as a global case
of diabetes
diabetes when it's treated is manageable
it depends on what we do and that's not
just about cutting carbon emissions it's
also
development makes us more resilient to
climate extremes of all sorts
malthus wasn't completely wrong about
the tendency of humans to deplete
resources says bayley
but he failed to see that new ways of
organizing society would ameliorate the
problem
up until about two centuries ago robert
thomas malthus was about right
is that in fact population was regulated
by food supply
and something changed the world
understood the role of property rights
for example the rule of law
and this dramatically changed the
incentive structures that people had
activists like naomi klein who
argued their economic system is at war
with their climate system
she wants to replace it with some sort
of communitarian socialism
i would suggest you that doing that
would exactly bring back the malthusian
conditions that we used to live in
the thing that we need to do is proceed
to produce more wealth more technology
in order to
ameliorate and overcome the problems
that climate change is going to cause
her prescription is exactly the opposite
of what needs to be done
we are in the beginning of a mass
extinction
and all you can talk about is money and
fairy tales of eternal economic growth
how dare you that's the kind of claim
that it doesn't actually
enlighten at all it doesn't actually
tell us anything about the real choices
we're faced with what sorts of social
and political and economic arrangements
we ought to aspire to
you know for a planet that is pretty
soon going to be 9 or 10 billion people
what it's not is going to be agrarian
traditional economies with 10 billion
people if you ever tried to
actually like have everybody live that
way we would just cut down every forest
in the world and then we would collapse
this is not real these are fantasies
she's going to go back to copenhagen
and live a very righteous life as an
international environmental celebrity in
a wealthy
city surrounded by extraordinary modern
infrastructure
most of which was built with fossil
fuels that's greta tunberg's future
and i would like that future for
everybody else on the planet
[Music]
you